Goes to show you,
I'm going to find that we're back up.
Sorry.
You stream how tweet everybody we're back up.
Yeah.
So the um,
you know that the way that the Shamans continued explaining fifth dimension is
the dream state.
Um,
that's you access that sleeping and you also access that on a general level in
psychedelic experiences.
Sixth dimension is the realm,
um,
is the spirit realm.
And uh,
the kind of the master that realm is the earth mother is nature itself.
So the snakes that came,
that yields,
that came,
that's the fifth amendment.
The sixth,
sixth,
that's the sixth.
And what are we in?
We're in the third,
third and fourth time operates Taj just time,
linear time.
And was in the fifth is the dream state.
The dream state.
Dream state.
The collective unconsciousness of all humankind is the fifth.
And that's why when you dream,
you can access things outside of yourself.
Um,
you know,
think of things that you wouldn't have thought of because if somebody else had
ever thought of it,
you know,
you can access that in the fifth dimension,
the dream state outside of time.
So then the sixth is,
you know,
that's the spirit realm.
That's where if you're going to communicate with any of these totem animals or
guides or anything,
and they actually say when you smoked DMT,
you get kind of dropped directly right in the sixth dimension.
And there's beings in there that you see and it's very common report from people
smoking Dmt did you see beings?
And it's because you get rocket shipped directly into the sixth dimension where
you're going to encounter these different beings that exist in that dimension.
Um,
but the overlord of that kind of dimension is his mother earth.
So a lot of the things you see are kind of animalistic based,
especially for the people in the,
in the junk.
Maybe there's different paradigms of that.
But then the seventh dimension beyond that is the realm of energy,
uh,
energetic vibration and large and large entities.
And that's where they say the ships came from for me was the seventh dimension.
And the purpose of the ships was to prepare me for travel to the eighth
dimension,
which is the realm of pure potentiality,
they call it,
where you can really affect change on all the dimensions before,
including the third and the fourth affect change in the physical body.
Basically access,
see things in your life,
have a completely different perspective outside of time.
And that's the eighth dimension.
Um,
kind of the final dimension that you can arrive.
So,
um,
you know,
they explained this all after after I had went through and then said,
okay,
this was where you were here.
This is why you're here.
And,
uh,
you know what,
based on my experience,
it might all sound crazy,
but it's a paradigm that,
that seems to work for me because I lived it and I was there and I did it.
And I saw,
you know,
I've seen the physical benefits of what happened when I got to be eight
dimensioned.
It wasn't like I just got there and no good stuff happened.
I mean,
my business,
the decisions I've made,
I've been huge.
You know,
things are going really well.
My health is great.
Uh,
my buddy's good,
but who knows,
that wasn't very scientific.
I'm not going to put that one up in the win column.
Uh,
cause I didn't.
I'm not,
you know,
I'm not that
what we experience in a hallucination in,
in that form isn't absolutely real,
but it's just we can't put it in a box.
Yeah,
you can't,
you can't weigh it.
You can't hit it with a hammer,
you know,
making noise,
you know?
Yeah.
But it's the idea that is just your imagination.
People like poo poo that like it's just your imagination.
What is your imagination man?
Your imagination is a crazy fucking thing.
All these neurons and cells are firing and somehow or another through these
ideas manifest themselves or they can manifest themselves as solid objects.
Like the person had figured out the wheel or the guy wore,
makes a fucking computer.
These are all real things that have somehow another emerged into this dimension
from this ether old dimension of thoughts and ideas and done it through a human
being.
And we look at it as like,
no big deal.
Like,
oh,
he thought of it and then he made it.
It's just his imagination.
Oh you were in the eighth dimension.
Sure you were.
That's just your imagination.
What the fuck is your imagination?
We are very light with our,
our appreciation of that and very light with are very lax with our all as far as
what,
what the,
the dimension of the imaginations brings us.
I mean it's,
that's a crazy fucking thing.
The idea that the uh,
the world of thoughts and ideas is actually some sort of an intangible
experience that's like right there.
And from that you can pull things out and create them in and put them and then
you stack them up on top of each other and you know,
and then their physical,
they become a different thing.
But it's from the imagination.
Everything is from the imagination.
So the idea you saying,
you know,
anybody that would,
critique it.
Oh you saw drag Lawrence.
Sure you're doing it.
You saw snakes.
That's just your imagination.
I don't know what that exactly means.
You know,
when,
when you see something,
even if it's a hallucination and it's changing your fucking life,
cause it's whatever it's teaching you or whatever it's showing you or whatever
leverage that it uses to pry your ego's grasp free of your life for whatever
amount of time that allows you to sort of reset your rpms and fucking start a
new with fresh purpose.
That's real.
Yeah.
That's fucking real.
That UFO you saw was real.
It was real.
You know what I'm saying?
What the fuck is the imagination?
Does someone have to pour alloy into a mold and carve those things on it for it
to be real?
Do you have to be able to walk up and hit it and make a claim for it to be real?
No.
It's just how it interacts with you.
Any kind of invention was made from your imagination,
so.
Sure.
So it's like,
who cares
if,
if they teach you how to make the next fucking computer,
then don't say,
who cares?
It's just your imagination.
Cause that shit might teach you something just like these,
uh,
tools from,
from,
you know,
the Egyptian Times.
They were,
you know,
tools out of their imagination.
Yeah.
And if you believe in things,
if you believe in things,
they have incredible power over you.
Yeah.
Both good and bad.
You know?
And who's to say that's not real.
You know,
there's like the,
the idea of the placebo effect.
Like I give you a sugar pill and all of a sudden you feel better because you
thought I gave you medicine.
Well,
still you feel better.
You know,
people have actually been cured of ailments because of the placebo effect.
So what the fuck is happening where people,
people have this misconception that it works only one way.
That you know that the body can affect the mind,
but the mind can affect the body.
Oh No,
you can't go backwards on that road,
but it's bullshit.
I mean,
your mind can make changes in your body.
How do you think these,
you know,
these people are able to do things like slow their heart rate or walk on coals
and not get burned.
I mean,
it's,
they're able to focus some kind of walked down coals who's to trick.
Maybe it is.
I don't think,
I've never walked on calls,
but whatever,
you just gotta keep moving.
Well,
what they can do things with pain.
I mean you should have these people who go to trans and really kind of stop the
pain from,
uh,
from affecting women and certain people whose beliefs of certainly heal things
that the doctors thought were impossible.
But the idea that the mind can't affect the body I think is one of the biggest
problems and misconceptions in western medicine.
It's certainly Ken,
we all know people who are super,
super negative,
one up getting really sick too.
That's,
that's real.
There's,
I've had moments in my life where my,
I was too stressed out and I wasn't balanced.
And those are almost always the moments where you want them getting sick.
And there's a direct correlation between that.
You know,
there's a direct correlation between positive energy and positive results in the
physical form.
Yeah.
You know,
they're all connected.
One of the DMT trips that I had never,
never forget this because it was a real life changing experience.
Um,
you know,
the DMT trip is like being shot through a cannon to the center of the universe
and all of a sudden you have all the information around you all the time,
but it's like they're slippery dolphins.
He can't grab them.
It's like all the information's there,
but it's like you can't harness it.
You don't,
you can't figure it out.
And it's very,
very overwhelming and it can be terrifying.
And in one trip that I had,
I got real scared in the middle of it and I started thinking all this negative
shit.
It just got away from me.
And um,
as I was thinking all this negative shit,
the DMT trip became black and green and dark and it became like Jag id and then
it just like,
it just looked harsh and it,
it looked like it started to be almost like cancerous.
It looked like it was growing and it was,
it was moving in in an asymmetrical way.
It was just fucked up.
It was.
And then I realized,
okay,
this you're thinking negative,
stop thinking negative,
think positive,
relax,
let go.
And as I'm saying all these things,
the colors are slowly changing and then when I completely relaxed and went boom
and it blossomed into these beautiful geometric patterns.
It's like once I started thinking positive and going,
oh,
okay,
this is just silly.
You can control your mind.
Think Po,
let go,
love,
boom,
boom.
It like showed me in a physical form,
like something that I could actually look at and watch.
I could see negative energy and positive energy and that the lesson was that
these can be controlled to a certain extent.
They can be managed and they can certainly be managed by your intent and your
attitude and your ideas.
Yeah,
no doubt about it.
I mean that's a,
it's a powerful lesson to learn is to be able to manage that.
Not only when you're on,
I mean it's psychedelic.
That's like,
that's like when you're in the,
that's the real game time,
you know,
that's the playoffs.
That's when you need to bring all your training and practice to bear because
it's,
everything is magnified.
You're under the microcosm.
You know you don't in a real intense moment,
you don't know yourself until you have a psychedelic experience.
You might think you know yourself,
but I guarantee you you're going to find out who you really fucking art when you
go deep.
And then when you go deep and you come back and you have to kind of assess
everything and you look at yourself through fresh eyes,
the the ego while you're sleeping,
while you're working,
while it's gaining ground,
it's like the fucking fed.
It's stealing money and just pocketing things and taking control over certain
areas.
It really is like the government,
and then you don't realize how fucking embedded it's becoming your system until
you have a blowout.
He till have a psychedelic boom blow out experience and that ego good.
Just shut the side.
Like,
you know,
like a fucking explosion and a comic book movie and the Ego's sitting in a tree
with half,
it's close off hanging from branches because it just got blown out,
you know?
Then,
then you get to see yourself again.
Then you get to see who you really are.
But the time off of that man,
you gotta be real careful because that ego,
he fucking gets out of that tree,
fucking brushes himself off and clings a whole deal and starts running shit
again.
Listen to it be a lot easier to just let me handle this.
I got this,
I got this dude,
you're the shit.
Okay you're going to do this because you're the fucking man.
Trust me,
have a seat,
I'm going to drive.
And then next thing you know the fucking Egos in control again,
your life is fucking confusing.
I think that's why it happens.
Even to the Shamans,
you know the masters,
this is not something that they're,
you know,
void of,
cause they get a lot of power in their little communities and things and so the
medicine has to bring them back.
Well you're,
you're a spiritual person,
but you're also,
I mean the idea of spiritual did the word is a weird tainted word.
Unfortunately the word spiritual,
so tainted,
you know,
automatically hippy nonsense comes into play when you start using that.
But the line is your,
you are thoughts and ideas,
but you were also a physical,
biological being a vehicle and just like your fucking car.
We have to change the oil and you have to make sure that spark plugs are in
[inaudible] setting correctly and make sure that the computers tuned up.
Uh,
you have to do that with your body as well.
Your body is a vehicle and if you ignore it,
much like your fucking car started spewing out black smoke and shits out and
dies on the road,
your body does the same goddamn thing it's your car can do.
If you don't maintain it correctly,
it will fuck with you.
It will fuck with you.
And you know,
and the ego is a part of the physical body.
You know,
it doesn't seem like it is because again,
you can't fucking measure it.
You can't beat on it with a hammer.
But it is a part of who every fucking living organism that wants to stay alive,
that has a conscious,
a consciousness and has the ability to recognize that it's here that has self
awareness.
The Ego comes into play because that's how you stay alive.
That's how you succeed.
That's how you get girls.
That's how you fucking get money.
You get money,
you work for the ego.
The Ego is,
it's a part of the machine,
but it can get away from you.
You've,
you know what you're saying there,
it touches on the very core of my entire philosophy in life,
which is balanced.
You know,
and that's what the warrior poet is.
It's the,
you know,
it's the Samurai that appreciates the cherry blossom tree.
You know,
it's the,
it's gladiator when he's walking through the fields of wheat and in,
you know,
appreciating that it's the ability to maintain that kind of balance of both the
physical side and the spiritual side and a,
and really that's,
I think the message I had one message to bring.
It's like you got to have both.
You can't just be this spiritual being only and go on these trips and stuff.
You got to hone your body.
You got to keep it healthy.
You got to be able to operate in this world because in this,
in this dimension you're in,
you know,
people aren't to,
lay down for you just because you have a higher spiritual truth.
Like you have to bring both aspects to bear.
And I think that's what we were supposed to do.
And I think every,
but almost everybody has to whack on either side.
You know,
there's the big muscle heads that are like,
oh yeah,
fuck that hippie bullshit crystals,
eighth dimension,
that fucking faggot.
And then there's this,
you know,
the other side of things that's like,
they have no sense of humor,
no sensor,
like almost academic in,
it's all energy.
It's all love.
It's all light.
And then someone fucking snatches their purse and they're like,
oh my God,
there's something wrong with the,
you know,
like protect your shit.
You know,
like both sides are applicable.
And I think that's where people are flawed and they're so vigilant about
protecting their little niche.
Like,
my shit is right.
I'll pound you if you drift,
you're wrong.
And if you believe something else and the other people are like,
you're just an ignorant ape,
you know,
on the other side of things and no one wants to kind of bridge that gap.
But our birthright is to have all of it.
And that's what we should strive for is complete balance in both of those
aspects.
And I think,
I'm hoping that's why,
you know,
some people will listen to kind of what I'm saying is because I tried it,
I tried to be able to do that.
Like I want to kick ass in business and still talk to people about,
yeah dude,
like I went to another dimension and it was crazy,
but I'm over here.
I'm going to be killing it,
you know,
in your world too.
So don't think I'm slipping,
you know?
That's what I'm trying to do.
And that's my goal.
A lot of people want to,
uh,
push aside or deny the importance of the physical world,
the,
whether it's capitalistic gains or whether it's keeping your body fit and
sexually attractive.
They want to deny the significance and importance of these things.
And the,
you know,
the meaning of these things almost as like a form of socialism because they
don't want to compete and they don't want to have to be sexually attractive.
And so women will say,
Oh,
is that what you care about?
you're shallow.
You care about what someone looks like,
no,
I'm a human being.
And if you're fat,
that's gross.
Okay.
That's just the way it is.
And you can pretend all you want and you know,
maybe you'll take fat with a grace personality,
uh,
over skinny.
That's a con.
Yeah.
Maybe to make some compromises and you know,
no one's perfect physically,
but let's be honest about what we're looking at and what you like and why you
like it.
And that goes with capitalism as well.
That goes with being a successful person.
You know,
there's a lot of people that think that some,
there's some things shallow about being monetarily successful and I think that's
a form of socialistic thinking as well.
It's like you want this to be a level playing field because you can't compete.
And that's really what it is,
you know?
And you've got to find your fucking place in the Sun Jack Ass.
And you know some people I will,
I will never be playing professional basketball.
I'm five foot eight and I don't run that good and it's just a fucking,
just the way of the world band and they ain't a fair world.
Okay?
You got your own hand.
This is your journey.
You deal with the hand that you're given and,
and,
and just find your fucking place.
But don't try to hold other people back.
Don't try to say there's something wrong with that girl being sexy as fuck.
Don't think there's something wrong.
But because that guy's got a six pack that makes girls wet,
you know when they see him,
you can't hate cause you're fat.
You can't hate your all.
But he's,
he shallow just going to the gym all day.
I'm sure he's really interesting to talk to him.
Maybe he is.
Maybe he's more interesting than you.
Stupid because guess what?
It only takes like an hour a day to work out.
You're telling me that all those other hours of the day he has to be doing
meaningless meathead.
Shit to make your paradigm work.
No,
you're just,
you just want to pull the playing field down.
You're not trying to level things now.
You're not trying to rise.
You're trying to,
everybody's above you,
your crabs in a bucket,
man.
Your social crabs in a bucket.
Yeah,
that's absolutely right.
Not a bitch is out there folks.
And most of them are men.
How about that?
Remember that when you hear whiny conti,
negative,
stupid shit from dudes,
you bitch,
saddle the fuck,
fuck
up.
Yeah.
It's uh,
you know,
I think back a long time ago,
and I think we've touched on this maybe on the last podcast,
but you know,
you had to go to war and in some countries you still do.
And I think that's why that Israeli dude was so cool.
Like everybody in Israel goes to war and he was like,
listen,
the kids are a little unruly or whatever.
But when you,
you know,
but the parents don't care because they know,
you know what 19 you're going to war.
Like Israeli army is active.
It's very active.
It doesn't rest,
you know?
So that's one kind of last people that's holding,
but still they're fighting with lasers and a lot of things.
I mean,
not this guy,
he was running it,
fighting with shit that we give them trippy situation.
Now there are about the size of Rhode Island and they're surrounded by no hate
them.
I know.
So countries all over the place to hate them and some of them have nuclear
weapons.
Yeah.
But the fact that each one
one has to be a warrior at some point,
you know,
I think it,
it impacts,
there's more character.
Yeah.
Impacts the culture.
And that's the way it used to be back in the Roman days,
you know,
I mean,
every philosopher,
like I said,
Socrates was a bad ass.
You know,
every philosopher had to be,
they ran campaigns with swords and stab barbarians in the throat and then talk
philosophy over some wine later.
And that's,
that aspect is largely ignored,
I think.
And,
and one of the,
one of the large,
uh,
sicknesses I think of our world is they are,
like you said.
Yeah,
we definitely talked about this before,
the coming of age ceremony.
The,
this,
the,
the ritualistic aspect of,
you know,
making a big deal of coming of age because I think that's something that's
missing from this world.
Cause I think that kids today,
like they don't know when they're a man,
you know,
one of your man,
you Manary 22,
23.
Yeah Man,
we dad still calls you a fuck head.
You need to borrow money.
He's still a man,
you know,
when do you become a man officially,
and then a lot of Eh,
you know,
cultures,
there's a ceremony,
you know,
like those,
uh,
the guys in the Amazon that do that bullet ant glove.
Yeah,
we saw that tree by the way.
Fuck Outta here.
It's an ant that bite you,
it stings you.
And it feels like your arm is being slammed in a car door for 24 hours
apparently is blinding,
unbearable pain.
And for the coming of age ceremony,
these crazy motherfuckers take these ants and they give these oven mitts and
they,
they make them themselves and these,
they're all poorest and they stuffed the ants in there so the ants can't go
anywhere.
And you have to shove your hands into these gloves filled with bullet ants and
mother fucker.
That looks scary.
That tears just streaming down these men's faces as they were going through the
ceremony.
Will you get through that?
Man,
you have the right to say you're a man now.
You know what I'm saying?
Like you feel like this is a very clear boundary of broken through and you know,
I wouldn't suggest bullet ants.
Yeah,
well look at what happened to Ari,
you know,
as you,
and a little bit,
but think about it.
I,
I often think about it,
home of
politics,
you know,
like,
I feel like politicians should have to fucking earn their place.
Like whether it's bullet answer,
like a five steps psychedelic,
you know,
trip where it's like,
all right,
you want wanna,
you want to lead us,
here's what you gotta do first.
You're going to go take a boga 24 hours is going to cure you of your addictions
of bucking blowing coke off,
gay intern cock,
whatever you're into.
It'll,
you know,
at least the Copart,
maybe not the gay in turn.
I don't think it ever cure that,
but uh,
you know,
whatever it's going to whatever your,
addictions are cigarettes,
heroin,
coke,
whatever,
a Bogo,
blast that out of you.
24 hours.
All right,
so you go from there.
And then I think they should have to do a fast for a week where they get smoked
out every day and have to control their hunger and not eat and think.
And then after that,
like maybe go and do the Io Osca,
you know,
and then from there,
bring a bipartisan group to a campfire where they all do mushrooms.
It just talk about ideas and shit and then hit fucking session all drop a cap,
a pure pharmaceutical grade MDM,
boom.
Now you're just making these people party.
But listen,
I can get those good drugs,
man.
Imagine how different it would be if they had to do some kind of,
imagine how different it would be if they had to go through bootcamp.
Just that go through some something that shows your character other than the
photographs of your cock that you send to your intern.
They busted him.
Another guy,
they busted another fucking politician t sending pictures of his cock today.
Some fucking new guys resigning.
I don't even know who he was.
Just some dumb ass who thinks it's okay to send pictures of his Dick through his
fucking cell phone.
Some chick who turns out to be working for the enemy.
Wow.
Yeah,
he was kind of set up.
Yeah.
He was set up.
He's a fucking fool.
He looked like a fat 50 year olds.
Probably couldn't believe he was going to get some pussy.
It's how I see your cock.
Okay,
here's my cock shit and next thing you know these pictures around the net and he
looks like a fucking idiot and now he's got to resign and God damn man,
they're allowed to do that though.
Just because they're,
they have their job.
They're not allowed to do that on their off time.
There's still men
because they pretending they're someone else because they pretend to be family.
Men with great Christian values and loyal to their wive and their vows.
But meanwhile,
they're sending cock pictures all over the fucking Internet.
And so you know that this is a person who's full of Shit.
And this is a person who can't be trusted.
His character can't be trusted because he's pretending to be something he's not.
It's not like Tommy Lee sending pictures of his Dick and you're like,
oh,
Tommy,
you know,
it's fucking Tommy Lee.
He's crazy.
He's married to Pamela Anderson.
We've all seen his dick.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like if Tommy Lee was sending pictures of his Dick to girls,
he'd be like,
well,
my Dick look like that.
I missed that.
It fixes of it though.
You know,
it's not like that.
When someone pretends to be something they're not,
and we know they're not,
we know that there.
There's no way.
Most politicians can really be the way they are.
You remember how John Edwards used to pretend he was until we found out he was
banging some other chick while his wife was dying of cancer and apparently
fucking physically threatened her and you know,
yeah,
he's a fucking use campaign funds to hide the fact that he was banging this
broad.
So now he's probably going to go to jail.
This is there.
It's fucking going after John Edwards.
But at one point in time,
John Edwards was this lawyer with good old fashion American values and pull them
up by your bootstraps,
you know,
work ethic and you know,
you,
you'd come to find out that it is impossible to be a pure person,
to be the guy that you're pretending to be,
to be a politician.
They push it back so far that eventually it pops out somewhere.
It blows out there dressing up like a tiger and taking pictures or Al Gore
fucking tries to get his dick sucked while he's getting a massage and the chick
wants a sec,
you know,
charge them with sexual assault.
You know,
there's some truth.
There's something,
something happened there.
You know,
I don't know what it was.
She might have overblown it.
He might've just rubbed his cock honor just as like a little tester.
Who knows what the fuck happened.
But whatever happened,
it's not what we thought Al Gore was.
We didn't think Al Gore was whipping his dick out and fucking hotels was getting
massaged.
We didn't think that was,
he was pulling girls on top of them.
We didn't think that was Al Gore.
I don't know if he did that,
but he did enough or got into a situation that was enough for him to get in
trouble.
You know?
I mean,
no one talks about what Winston Churchill did with his women like that.
That was like,
it didn't fucking matter.
Fighting the Nazis.
He was kicking ass.
And I think all our politicians now,
they're so fraudulent.
And what their kind of projecting that it does matter at this point.
It's like you're a hypocritical lying little bastard.
But if they were real,
like really doing shit and very honest with what they're attacking and the
issues they were attacking were honest and they were coming from a real place.
It's like,
oh yeah,
our fucking fearless leader after a big,
you know,
a tough night.
He had some,
you know,
sexual indiscretion,
whatever,
you forgive that stuff.
But when they build this foundation full of,
you know,
puritanical nonsense,
then they do that.
They feel like that's the only way to get elected though.
And there's so much power in bullshit today with the idea of the Christian
ideology and the,
you know,
the Christian,
right.
And the fucking,
you know,
so Uber judgmental and that,
that there's,
that's a big political push because those people were organized.
Those,
those,
the really right wing Christian fundamentalists that,
that movement,
that's a very organized movement.
And if they're on your side,
you can do a lot of damage.
And if they're against you,
it can really hurt.
You know,
if they do organize the churches and they all said pull out and they say,
well,
this is fucking,
Al Gore doesn't believe in Jesus.
Oh fuck him.
You know,
they'll go crazy.
You have to fake that you believe in Jesus,
whether you do or not,
you better say you do because you're,
if you say you don't,
you're going to piss off 50 fucking percent of the country and you're never
gonna get anything done.
Yeah,
yeah.
Fuck situation.
And I think that's why,
you know,
there's the shamans down there when they talk about 2012 they talk about it just
as a tipping point.
But that,
that's like,
that's,
they talked about it.
Yeah.
Well they said that 2012 is the tipping point.
That's when the
world has to start changing and it will,
uh,
upheavals will happen.
They don't know if it's going to be economic.
They don't know if it's going to be,
you know,
physical,
it's not the end of time or anything like that.
And that was,
it was kind of cool to hear them talk about it.
So like that's all nonsense.
It's all hype.
What it is is it's the point at which things must start changing for us.
Why is there a date?
Why is it,
do I think it's December 21st,
2012 or was it 2012 at all?
It's to a astrological restaurant.
Comical kind of event,
right?
Isn't there some kind of
the alignment I've heard,
I didn't,
obviously I'm not an astronomer,
but I've heard Neil Tyson talk about how that's bullshit into that.
That event happens all the time that everyone's talking about how it aligns with
the center of the galaxy and he's like can always does to happens all the time.
Yeah.
Well,
so I don't know.
I don't exactly know how they got the date.
I mean I think it was tied to some kind of of going on
in this,
in the,
in the idea of astrology and astronomy,
there's so much going on where you know,
they can figure out that the moon is off a little bit with its gravity and then
they have to figure out what is responsible for this error and the moon's
gravity will,
it could be a brown dwarf star that lays,
you know,
a hundred million miles outside of Pluto.
And that's like the current theory is in it.
But they can figure that out.
They can figure it out.
They couldn't measure gravity and know that there's errors in places and try to
like figure out what y where's this error coming from.
So we know that that for sure that the moon's effect and its particular gravity
has an effect on tides.
We believe it has an effect on human behavior,
although that's all subjective.
But we,
we know that these little bodies or these,
these,
these motions and these,
these things that we can't quite grab a hold of have a very physical effect on
the earth.
Like in the tide w who knows how many different things are doing that all the
time with the procession of the equinoxes,
the fact that the earth wobbles on its access,
uh,
26,000 year cycle.
And in between that times,
you know,
you never know what is aligned with what,
when you were brought into this world and that the idea behind astrology as
fucking flaky and new agey and bullshitty as it sounds,
is that these events,
these alignments of stars and positions of,
of the moon and all these different things,
they actually affect how a human being is charged as they're set loose from the
vagina into the world.
You know,
that it,
that it actually has on it and it look,
it fucking,
I know a lot of Leos,
it seemed like Leo's,
you know,
I know a lot of cancers that act like cancer.
I mean,
fuck it sounds like utter horse shit,
but God damn it's fucking clothes.
It seems,
it seems damn close.
Yeah.
So yeah,
I mean,
I don't know exactly what the,
uh,
what the event is that they named the date for.
They didn't go into that.
But what they said is that a new type of person has to emerge at that point and
that the old ways have to change and they will and that things will get fucked
up enough where they have to.
It's like,
it's not like we all got a rally and you,
but we do.
And when we do it to a certain degree,
we have to prepare for it,
but it'll,
it'll force itself to happen.
So we just need to be ready for it as what they're saying.
Like the new era is going to come and it's going to happen either complete
economic upheaval,
physical upheaval of the earth.
Um,
whatever's going to happen is going to force our hand.
And then the new people are going to have to emerge.
They call it the legend of Catsa Quadel defense,
the feathered serpent.
But really that represents the new type of human that comes and starts taking a
leadership role.
So all of these cock picturing politicians and everything,
whatever they believe is going to happen is going to change that paradigm where
all of a sudden that becomes deemphasized either faith in them gets lost,
a new system as to emerge.
New leaders,
new,
you know,
political.
Is this,
the Shamans have actually explained this to you?
Yeah.
Did they talk about the Internet?
Are they on Twitter?
How come on,
you can tell,
you can tell the mountain the mountain shamans are dim at different than the
jungle shamans.
But you can tell a good mountain Sharman by how much he smells like burnt Lama
Shit because that's how they stay warm up in the high parts.
So it'd be really be really,
look,
it really smells like burnt Lama Shit.
You know,
he's probably authentic cause then he's up up above 15,000 feet for most of
them.
Jesus Christ,
but no cell phone,
no Internet.
And he's missing the cool youtube videos.
Some one of them,
one of the guys that had,
uh,
I was talking with,
had a,
at a full URL at the bottom of his little corner.
So they're starting to adapt to it.
Nice seeing you.
They need that.
There's,
you know,
people poo poo the cultural experience,
because it's filled with morons and lady Gaga fans.
But there's nothing wrong with lady Gaga.
Okay.
That's part of the trip and I think she's fascinating.
I like some of her music.
How about that?
And there's nothing wrong with the rest of the cultural experiments.
Even the most ridiculous aspects of it.
It's all part of us,
you know?
And you don't want to be locked out.
I don't buy that being locked out when I talked to someone and go,
I don't know if you have an email,
well you're a fucking moron.
How about that?
You don't want an email.
You don't want people to be able to send you cool shit that you can read.
You didn't want photos.
That'll blow your mind.
You don't want someone turning you on to some fucking article that might change
your life.
You don't want that.
Okay,
you're cool too cool for that.
What are you going to do?
Sniff flowers.
You fucking Weirdo
for them.
It's like,
I mean,
really,
do they want to just affect only the few people in the village?
If you're a real shot and be like,
yeah,
fuck yeah,
I want to get my word out there.
I want to make change.
I want to make things happen.
And I think it goes back to kind of what Pressfield says about professionals,
like the professional,
the shamans down there were professionals.
They're not trying to be shamans.
They just fucking are.
That's their job.
That's what they do.
And they're professionals at it.
So yeah,
the Internet comes along,
they analyze that tool and they're like,
oh yeah,
that's cool.
You know?
Or if something funny happens in the middle of their ceremony,
they're not like,
I better not laugh.
Or people might think that I'm not a showman.
You know?
They're like,
they'll fucking crack up and be like,
ah.
And then they'll just get back to their work when they're done.
They don't take themselves so seriously that it's like anything could shake the
experience.
It's not for other people.
They're going to do their work and whatever happens when they do their work,
that's fine.
They go with it.
And that was something I really appreciate it because even when you get out here
in this kind of slightly pseudo spiritual thing,
it's like they're putting on an act,
you know,
like the music has to be perfect and
the candles have to grow with the right and the crystal has to be without
impurities,
you know?
And they're like,
okay,
you know,
if they use rocks,
they're like,
this is a good rock,
you know,
and it just looks like a fucking rock
spiritual bullshit.
Spiritual talk is the grossest shit.
Yeah.
I got married by a hack.
We got some lady off the Internet that married.
I said,
oh,
it was brutal.
Your love is two streams that will become together a growing river.
It will wash over the rocks of the world.
Like,
oh,
you crazy bitch.
There was no feeling to it at all.
Like as she was saying it,
there was no connection to the words.
It was just utter spiritual nonsense because it was a nondenominational wedding,
obviously,
because I'm not religious.
Nora's Mrs Rogan.
So it had a listen to this nonsense crystal sucking fucking ideas.
Marriott world of Narnia.
Yeah.
This bitch lived at totally in Narnia.
She had a hut in Narnia.
It was brutal.
This,
um,
I found the article about the Colombian showman.
He was arrested in Texas and charged with IOWASCA possession.
He flew into the Houston airport.
And the crazy thing about being charged with Iowasca possession is the plants
that you use to create Iowasca or not even illegal.
That's the weirdest aspect of it.
You know,
I met the guy from bouncing bear botanicals.
He came to my show in Vegas.
Yeah.
Uh,
if you don't know the story,
there was a guy who ran a website called bouncing bear botanicals and it's a
website all dedicated to selling legal plants that have psychedelic properties
to them.
Like the San Pedro Cactus that you could buy at fucking home depot.
Yeah.
Well you can make Mescalin out of that shit.
You can,
you can open that bitch up,
make some Payoti if you know what you're doing and trip your balls off.
This is off some shit that you just buy at home depot and it's totally legal.
It's a beautiful cactus and a lot of people don't even know about the
psychedelic properties of it.
They have it just to decorate their garden because it's pretty,
but it's not illegal.
So they,
they,
he has this there,
he's selling this,
he's selling the different circuitry had Veritas and the different plants that
you mix to make Iowasca he's selling those.
He's selling Salvia.
I sang all these different plants that are absolutely legal morning glory seeds.
You know a lot of people don't know that morning glory,
seeds,
just those regular fucking seeds that you buy when you go to plant to make
flowers.
Well the ones that you buy,
most of them,
they've been treated so that they are not psychoactive because regular morning
glory seeds,
you can grind those bitches up and eat them and you'll trip your fucking balls
off.
Hell yeah.
So untreated,
they're still your,
their legal,
you can buy the untreated
ones.
It's hard to get,
it's hard to get the untreated ones.
You're supposed to treat them because the government is aware of the psychedelic
properties of them.
Meanwhile,
you know,
of course it's not nearly as dangerous as cigarettes or alcohol or any of the
things they sanction,
but it's to mind bending for the government allowed the unwashed masses to
participate in.
So your wise daddy government is figured out how to neuter this incredibly
brilliant psychedelic plant to the point where most people aren't even aware of
its properties.
But regular morning glory seeds was Terence Mckenna's first psychedelic trip.
That's what sent him on his fucking wacky journey of,
you know,
being psychedelic Shawman of the,
the new world.
Um,
and that was a,
you know,
a common thing that people did in the 70s and the 60s before the government got
hip to it.
They were just tripping balls and morning glory seeds,
you know.
So this guy,
this John or he says that was saying from bouncing bear botanicals.
Anyway,
there's two dudes that I met that came,
they were high as fuck there was so high,
I can barely talk to them after the show.
They came to my last Vegas show and I talked to them outside and that swarm of
people,
remember there's all two of those of those crazy guys.
They were trying to have like a serious conversation with me.
Me,
it was like 500 people trying to take pictures and they want to hold on in my
hand and talk to him.
I'm like,
dude,
wasn't a lot of people here.
I can't remember to talk to you about your arrest.
Glad you're doing the right thing.
Glad you got out.
But apparently they let him out of jail.
They had to let him out eventually because,
uh,
there's,
you know,
there's nothing he can fucking charge him for there.
There's nothing that said that he was making drugs trashed.
His place crashes,
confiscated all the state.
I don't know if he got his money back,
but they froze all that as well for nothing,
for nothing.
Because the government is scared of psychedelics.
It's amazing how scared they are of it.
And I guarantee you they're scared of it because they're not experiencing it.
It's that simple.
Like when you get into like Alex Jones believes crazy shit.
Like he believes that the elites were all smoking DMT.
Like they're all up in,
you know,
Hilton Talk to you about,
they're all in fucking and shit where Guantanamo Bay,
they're all down in Guantanamo Bay and they are smoking DMT,
connecting to the spirit world.
They believe in eternal life what they're going to do.
And he'll tell you all this nonsense that he absolutely positively believes in,
but I believe 100% you cannot smoke DMT and not be empathetic towards other
people that are doing it.
You cannot take Iowa school or mushrooms without being empathetic and wanting
other people to do it.
These people that are trying to keep everybody from it,
those are the people sending their dicks to their fucking secretaries and their
emails.
Those are the fucking hypocrite,
hypocritical shitheads with huge flaws and their character that we have running
this country and running this world.
And unfortunately that's,
that's one of our biggest issues are what we considered leaders.
We know for sure that it's a bullshit scam and we allow it.
We have,
we have resigned ourselves.
We know that the president has speech writers.
We know that everyone has a bunch of people that will review every word that
he's going to say and it's going to be calculated and they're going to sit down
and come up with the,
the the right words and enact the most emotional impact to the point where they
even fucking,
they used to plagiarize other people's speeches before they got busted for it.
Joe Biden,
our own fucking vice president used to plagiarize.
He blew plagiarized Kennedy Shit.
Well,
they caught them doing that in 1,988 that's why he had to quit running for
president,
you know,
and that's why he had to like sit in the background and wait for everybody to
kind of forget about it before he could be vice president.
You know,
we know for a fact that it's,
it's a,
it's a bullshit hustle.
We're all aware of lobbyists.
We're all aware of special interest groups and corporations donating millions of
dollars.
We're all aware that the supreme court changed the ruling so that a corporation
can now act as an individual.
So they can donate as much fucking money as they want,
which is absurd.
The idea that a corporation that would rely on politicians and their,
their,
their decisions to make money in a way that may or may not be ethical,
but they'll rely on and then they just donated x amount of fucking millions of
dollars towards this person.
It's insane.
It's amazing.
And we accept it for now because things are relatively placid,
you know?
Yeah.
We have some little few financial difficulties,
but whatever people's lives,
they go on and we go and you know what they're saying about 2012 is had at
certain point things aren't going to be fucking plastic anymore.
And at that point we're not going to accept that bullshit.
We're not going to expect except these weak ass politicians who don't really
stand for anything to lead us anymore.
So what's going to happen?
Who the fuck knows?
They don't know.
They don't have the answer,
but they're going to say some type of new person is going to have to emerge and
be like,
Yo,
this is bullshit.
Like we needed to make some changes now.
Like things are getting fucked up,
even worse and worse.
Have you seen the,
the,
the numbers that they did when they were,
they did an audit of the,
uh,
the Fed to find out where the fucking money went for the bailout and they found
trillions of dollars that went to these weird fucking overseas banks.
And it's totally beyond description how much corruption and ridiculous bullshit
is involved and how little accountability there is for this distribution of,
of the taxpayers wealth.
I mean,
it's a fucking free for all,
man.
It's craziness.
So it's to say that there's a few financial difficulties.
The whole thing is built on this foundation of unfixable bullshit and there's no
solution in sight.
Yeah,
that's worse.
I mean,
that is getting more credit rating about to be downgraded.
China already did.
They downgraded our credit rating even though we didn't default,
even though we raised our,
our,
our debt ceiling,
they're like,
these bitches are like on the edge.
You know,
it's like when you try to get too many loans,
even if you pay your loans back,
the banks are going,
why are you asking for all this money?
Dude,
what are you,
what's going on with you?
But you've got a gambling problem.
But yeah,
it's,
it's not,
it's not fucking getting fixed in the system.
And this,
the,
the way it's set up right now and the model that we're operating under,
it's not getting fixed and everyone's frustrated.
No one knows that knows what to do.
And me like you,
like I'm the fucking completely full of Shit.
All I do is just complain about it.
And then I go about my day and as long as I have food in the refrigerator and I
have the ability to use my credit card to buy gas,
I'm only gonna Yap too much.
You know,
it almost like it has to fall apart on all of us before we step back and we go,
all right,
well now we have to admit
doesn't work right?
Well what you're doing,
but you're doing something more important than that,
I think as well,
is that you're creating a movement of consciousness.
I mean every time new people turn it tune in,
you know you have their ear and these people,
but I have no activated of no,
there's no crisis yet necessarily.
Right.
It's sort of where is though.
No,
kind of.
Probably if we had the foresight to really look ahead and start doing things
now,
but it's not pressured enough like it's not beating down our door so it's just
really not going to happen.
Realistically,
we probably not that we shouldn't try and do it or whatever.
I'm not saying that,
but so much work though.
That's the problem.
If you want to live your life at some point when things get fucked,
you know you may have,
this is the Joe Rogan fucking emergency podcasts.
Listen,
like this is what needs to happen.
Like seriously and you'll have,
you'll have that power like fucking John Connor for your own small people of
conscious fucking humans who are going to be able to then go out and like,
all right,
everything we're being fed is nonsense.
Don't use it.
The shit goes down.
The Internet is going to be the first thing they shut off.
They tried to do that in another country.
So they have,
they've done it.
But yeah,
there were did in Libya when they do it in Egypt,
Egypt.
But there was still ways around it.
People were still getting mad.
He's going to intentionally fuck us.
I just think they're going to be incapable of helping us at that point.
You know,
like that's my personal belief.
I don't think I'd be like,
shut the internet down.
It's just gonna be like,
ah,
what do we do?
We're a bunch of,
you know,
we've never fucking stuck our hand in a glove full of ants.
We are not ready for this shit
either.
Or though.
Right.
Good Bait could come either or.
I mean,
there's a reason why they do these fucking FEMA tests and they have,
you know,
giant stockpiles of plastic coffins,
that's all been documented.
They've prepared,
they have a lot of drills they prepared for mass extinction events and you know,
big,
huge environmental catastrophes.
Natural disasters.
I mean,
the government has camps,
they have FEMA camps and these are real,
you know,
this is Alex Jones.
You know when he'll,
he'll start talking about FEMA camps,
but there's,
there's a real,
they're really do have places where they have cots set up and they have,
they have fucking,
almost like a prisoner of war camp because if the shit really does hit the fan,
you know,
we get wiped out in nuclear war or you know,
or,
or a fucking asteroid hits or something nutty that fucks up the world.
We really are going to have to detain a lot of people were really going to have
to calm everybody the fuck down.
If we're going to evacuate areas,
we're going to have to have places to shelter these people.
We're going to have to have buses were women and children are crying and they're
being separated from the father and the father sitting there with a son and
we'll meet you at the camp and then that's real shit and they're going to get on
buses and we're not going to know where everybody is and we're not,
some people are not going to be,
that's possible.
This is a fucking fragile world we live in.
Yeah,
it's possible.
You know,
and little,
and then little colonies will get set up.
Individuals will have different,
you know,
who knows how the,
but the structure could break and at that point some new system can emerge.
It's almost,
that's when we have to bring in the Colombians bringing that fucking Iowasca
donkeys in big clay pots riding on the back of Don.
He's in the whole wage.
Oh Ya,
Ya go?
Yeah.
You got it,
man.
Yeah,
I can get in there,
dude.
I could get down.
I can get done with the Iwatch carols.
You Cut.
So what'd they say about smoking DMT?
Would they say?
Well,
they said that
that's just kind of a,
it's kind of a rocket ship that plants you right in that it right in that sixth
dimension,
but only the sixth dimension.
The seventh and the eighth,
they say mostly.
Mostly not because it's too short of an experience.
You can't really,
you have to kind of gather steam through the,
through the dimensions or something like that.
And the smoking DMT kind of skips over the fifth where you usually kind of start
getting in these dreams.
It's like Wham,
Bam into the six.
And that's why they say that there's some disorientation there.
A lot of lessons to be learned and wisdom.
Anytime you sneak outside of time,
which is how they describe it as sneaking outside of time,
you have lessons to learn,
but they're,
you know,
once you're there you have a short window of time and you're trying to absorb as
much as possible.
Um,
but the forces aren't there to align you to help,
you know,
kind of push you farther because that's,
that's a process you have to gain knowledge.
Like what happened to me,
I had to download something or whatever they said in the seventh to get,
you know,
to get that far.
They're like,
just have more steam and energy to get there.
And they talk about it as fuel.
You know,
the problem with the smoking DMT is the fuel runs out.
They have enough fuel to like get you into orbit,
you know,
but it's not that extra afterburner that's going to come in and shoot you to
Mars after you're outside of the atmosphere.
You know,
eventually it's just going to suck you right back in.
And so that's what they say.
The,
the differences
between those,
the interesting because the intravenous doses of DMT that like Strassman did in
those studies,
those people had 30 minute trips.
That's,
so I wonder if that's enough.
I wonder if that's a different teacher to a different place.
I didn't get to ask as opposed to be a more intense experience when it's
experienced.
Um,
when it's done intravenously,
it's supposed to be more a more in depth and a lot more entities.
Yeah.
A lot more people being uh,
you know,
more of what they would describe.
That sounds remarkably similar to Ufo abduction experiences.
You know,
that kind of thing that you're dealing with these physical things in this other
place.
Yeah.
It's a real fucking symptom of our culture that that shit's all illegal.
That people can like,
you can come back and you get so fucked up that you have to change your name and
it's still illegal.
It's illegal.
You know,
a,
it's really annoying.
It's really annoying that we're in this fucking nanny state.
It's shitbag stupid nanny state country.
Yeah.
Do you find you any side effects at all?
Like does your mind wander in places over and over again?
Do you have any different now?
What was the,
some of the challenges were just reintegrating,
you know,
and a lot of that's just you to this different world and experience different
things and,
but do you leave your life on the treadmill running full speed,
you know?
And I tried to hop right back the fuck on and I got tripped up and slammed
against the back wall.
You know?
Do you use that analogy?
Like it's hard to get back,
you know,
and hard to find,
kind of the balance of integrating what,
what you found out they're not.
But
do you guys feel like the world doesn't seem the same when you,
when you came back,
do you feel that anything's changed in the world?
No.
You know,
I,
I feel like,
you know,
I've,
I've changed the way I look at things has changed.
You know,
the fact that I can,
I view myself now more like a needle piercing a nine layered onion.
You know,
and I'm,
you're consciously aware of the first four,
four layers,
you know,
that part of the needle,
but you're still connected to another five layers above you and you're just,
you just don't see it,
you know,
just that very thought alone has changed,
has changed my life.
You know,
it's hard to incorporate in every day and everyday things.
I mean,
I've been focused pretty much solely on launching Alpha brain and making sure
that all goes well and it's been very,
you know,
very focused on that.
But in my quiet moments,
you know,
when I can meditate,
I can think back and think,
you know,
what I want to do next time I go down there and what lessons I could learn and
how,
oh,
he did an isolation tank son.
That's your next step.
I do.
We sell some of these Alpha brains enough to get you one morning glory.
And so this is,
this is the shit that we've been talking about on Twitter and we've talked about
it on the podcast before and this is a formula that Chris has put together and
that we're selling and it's called Alpha brain,
and it fucking does something man.
It first of all,
it gives you incredibly vivid dreams and it seems to fire up your brain at a
higher rpm level or give you some clarity.
I feel like it helps me form sentences better,
you know?
You know what I'm saying?
I mean,
I don't know that that's what's doing it,
but I feel like,
man,
I'm fucking talking pretty smooth sometimes when I'm on this stuff.
Technically what they say is that it enhances Sydney synaptic plasticity,
which is the way that your neurons can kind of fit together and transfer
information
that,
was this all peer reviewed stuff or is it spiritual?
No,
it's a c rolling.
Yeah.
This is,
this is purely on the scientific tap here.
And what's it,
what's in here?
So what it is,
it's
a GPC calling,
which is a great form of rock hauling,
the best form of rock.
Coleen really glycerophosphocholine easily absorbed through the blood brain
barrier where some of the other Coline's or not.
So it's most expensive and best calling for you.
And then we have hoopers Ia Serrata,
which has a proven compound called huperzine a,
which is an Acetylcholine esterase inhibitor and that prevents the breakdown of
the Acetylcholine in your brain.
And what does see the calling is in charge of is in charge of,
you know,
focus,
memory,
clarity,
uh,
all the Alzheimer's treatments.
Currently almost all of them focus on rehabilitating your acetylcholine levels
in boosting your acetylcholine.
So even who presented a,
which is part of the Hoop Herzliya Serrata has been tested in that capacity.
So this is all very,
you know,
very scientifically proven.
This is not anything Hokey pokey is just the fact hire a pseudo cdot.
Coleen levels lead to this.
Now the problem with higher acetylcholine levels,
otherwise everybody would just be jacked jacking their acetylcholine up,
is it can lead to anxiety,
anxiousness,
a short temper.
If that's too out of balance,
you can get other,
you can get kind of hyper aware.
And so what I did with this formula,
as I said,
all right,
we want to have strong acetylcholine.
It's good,
it helps your memory,
helps your mental drives,
help you focus.
But we don't want to have all the other things.
So I created a balanced formula and I included things like Gabba which controls
kind of relaxation and kind of calm and mental clarity in that kind of calm
state.
And then dopamine,
which handles a lot of your movement activities and some of your mental energy
activities.
Yeah,
added dopamine.
Well,
um,
it's Mucuna pruriens uh,
contains a standardized dose of 50% ELL Dopa and um,
you can appear.
Ends is a herb,
I think,
believe it grows in India.
And so the 50% standardized l Dopa is the building block for dopamine.
So yeah,
I didn't add dopamine.
I actually,
you're able to add a Gabba directly because they're able to extract it from a
plant.
But the dopamine you have to get through,
you know,
pushing l Dopa and your body,
your body will destroy it opened me.
And if you try to put it in directly so you build it yourself with El Dopa,
uh,
the catalyst and that is again,
um,
the pyridoxine Hcl,
vitamin B six which we have in there,
which helps convert it.
So,
and then,
then I've just put a ton of antioxidants that are going to give you energy,
uh,
help your focus.
The ACA 11 in there that was shown to actually repair DNA and uh,
scientific peer reviewed studies.
So really fucking strong antioxidants going to kind of eliminate some of that
mental fog,
cleared out some of your free radicals and then allow the acetylcholine a boost
to be manageable by the other,
by the other components.
Yeah.
Have you ever thought about adding five HTP to it?
Now that's another formula that I have and Serotonin is a crucial component.
Five HTP is the direct building block of Serotonin.
Um,
it goes l Tryptophan to five HTP,
five ht HTP then converts to five ht,
which is serotonin.
That's the fourth component.
I have another separate formula,
the rollover formula,
which is specifically focused on building serotonin.
So,
uh,
being the fact that I have that there,
there's just not that much room in the capsules and it is important to have,
but I recommend that,
um,
you know,
that doesn't tend to,
that doesn't need to be so much in balance for this formula to work,
but it is a crucial part of things.
So I recommend either taking my formula or another form of five HTP,
but it was just a little bit much to fit and efficacious dose of five HTP in
this Alpha brain to bring that forth component.
It,
that's too bad because I know a lot of people that have had a lot of positive
effects with the five HTP is great.
That's why I have a whole product rowboat and roll over,
roll over.
Yeah.
My product rollover is dedicated specifically to that.
So you have a,
you're selling those and much smaller selling
like four of those bottles,
a 30 get bottles of 30 just like this.
Yeah.
And so do you recommend people taking that?
If they're not coming off of,
uh,
you know,
the roll on roll off,
it's supposed to be like you do Mtma and then you're welcome anytime.
If you're not sleeping,
if you're stressed and you're not sleeping,
that's when Serotonin is produced is when you're sleeping.
So if you're not sleeping,
it doesn't matter if you're partying and if you are doing,
doing whatever you're doing,
you're not going to be producing enough serotonin.
Right.
So that's when you need to take it.
Uh,
so yeah,
I certainly recommend taking it as part of the regimen.
I mean that formula will probably change a little bit and the next iteration I
have some ideas for it,
but I'm going to always have a serotonin specific formula.
Um,
you know,
if,
if enough people want to have this Alpha brain be that complete brain thing,
we can look at it.
But just as far as dose and capsule size,
it's difficult to do everything.
I mean,
I have a capsule that's specifically designed for Serotonin,
the whole capsule capsule.
It'd be way too much.
It's tough.
So you,
so that one was something that I do recommend I do sell on,
on at.com,
but,
um,
it's not in the Alpha brain,
but I highly recommend it.
It's a great,
it's a great thing to have.
I use it all the time.
I love it.
I don't take it every day,
but I definitely take it on like days where I for sure feel jacked up in it.
I think I,
I've been taking for like,
I don't know,
like six,
eight months here and there and I,
I,
it's one of my favorite things.
I though the roll on and roll overs are my two favorite things.
Yeah.
Those,
so those formulas will change a little bit,
but I'm still going to always keep that kind of concept and not,
you know,
the Alpha brains,
it's getting great feedback.
I know,
you know,
all of us here,
we all take it and we dig it.
So,
uh,
there's something going on with it.
Most certainly does have an effect.
Um,
like I said,
it gives me the most incredible dreams.
Okay.
So the reason why that's happening is acetylcholine regulates rem sleep.
That's what determines,
you know,
you get a wash of Acetylcholine,
uh,
during your rem sleep.
So the fact that you have excess surpluses of Acetylcholine created by the GPC
calling her Perseus serrata allows a deeper and broader wash of Acetylcholine to
go through,
uh,
your sleep cycles.
And so your rem sleep becomes way more intense,
longer and more vivid then,
uh,
when you do have low levels of Acetylcholine.
All right,
so if you guys want to grab this,
it's available now and on it.com o n n I t.com.
And uh,
it's called Alpha brain.
And tell me how you like it.
I know some people have already started taking it and uh,
I have yet to talk to one person that hasn't had positive experiences with it.
And um,
it's uh,
no,
what is it,
30 bucks for 30 of these things.
And people say,
oh,
it's expensive,
but look,
this,
the stuff's not cheap stuff.
It's,
it's what's needed to actually have an effect.
Yeah,
I went expensive the best.
I got the best ingredients I could,
you know,
I cut no corners.
Everything's full spectrum standardize.
So this is the best product I can make and you know,
I hope people dig it because I fucking,
I played my cards as well as I can and,
and tried to make the best in every aspect of doing it.
Yeah.
Thanks for coming on and talking about your psychedelic experience that made you
change your name.
I mean we thinking get you drunk on Jack Daniels and you go to B and Duke turn
you into some sort of fucking,
after listening to that story though,
I would definitely change my name to it seems like,
and you've actually got to sit in that thing and we talked with the ancient
aliens guy,
the the big square that was cut out.
You got to,
you got the crew.
Yeah.
He's got a photo of him sitting in there.
When we were talking to a Joe Su,
Su sucralose from a ancient aliens,
he was talking to us about this area in Peru where this stone is cut out and you
could see it,
if you'd go to the Ustream page,
he put a picture of Chris,
excuse me,
Aubrey sitting inside this,
this rock where it was cut out where they have no idea how they cut it out
because it was,
it's really,
you have to see it.
What is the name of the place again?
It's in the roads in the sacred valley.
I forget the name of this actual ruin site,
uh,
calming to me,
but it's,
um,
I,
it was right there near,
uh,
you know,
it's outside of Cusco by about an hour and a half and you get to these ruin
sites.
Either way,
it's dope.
Go get some Alpha brain stupid.
Yeah.
It does seem like one of the places too bad he can't do Iowasca there.
That would be the shit.
Yeah.
I think that sounds fucking bad ass do Iowasca at Chichen Itza or Machu Picchu
or something like that.
Yeah.
At the ruins of some ancient civilization.
That that's what they,
that's what they develop Machu Picchu for as a spiritual center.
Actually really it wasn't like a political center.
This was their spiritual home.
Where did you hear that?
The rituals?
Um,
the people there for me cause I thought the cause modern Western folks have no
fucking idea why it was created.
They don't have an idea.
No,
he had the Shaman Saul say this was there,
this was created as their spiritual home and that's,
and that's why they created it in such an odd spot.
The way that the mountains are around.
There's speaking of law civilizations,
I'll be in Milwaukee
August 13th at the Pabst theater with Joey Coco Diaz.
Tickets are on sale right now and uh,
it's like half sold out already,
so don't sleep.
And then also on September 23rd,
Joey and I will be in Denver,
Colorado at the paramount theater.
And that is also just about half sold out now Denver showing lots of love.
I can't wait to come back to Colorado where I will eventually go when the shit
hits the fan and society crumbles.
And I have to live in the woods near where my dog died.
Folks,
that's the end of this fucking show.
We've had a fantastic time.
Chris and I are going to go check out red state.
We're going to go see the premiere of Kevin Smith new movie and we'll have a
full report on that.
Thank you very much for tuning into the podcast.
Please follow Chris on Twitter.
His,
excuse me,
Aubrey is his name,
his warrior poet,
That's on Twitter.
Follow Red Ban.
He's very upset about his Twitter numbers.
Obsesses on it on a daily.
And why you ran it.
Follow me to your fucking freaks.
We're not falling Joe already.
You're ridiculous.
How dare you.
How dare you if you're not following me.
I'm trying to hit a million people.
I'm only at 413,000.
I don't feel validated.
All right.
That was a moment of weakness.
Back to reality.
Thank you everybody for tuning in.
We uh,
we love you all and uh,
we,
we wish you well on your spiritual journey through the world of snakes.
Did and go to that with a fleshlight end.
If you go to Joe rogan.net thank you.
The fleshlight for sponsoring the podcast.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click the link for the flashlight and entering
the code named Rogan,
you will get 15% off the number one sex toy for men,
and then you can shoot loads at a discount.
How the Shama feel about sex toys?
Are they cool with that?
I think they're down.
He's got like five kids though.
Have you could use,
you could use one day.
Pulled up on his urges.
She was not shy about sex out there.
Shazamm we'll see next week.
Love you.
Bye Bye.
[inaudible].